tomorrow the president's lawyers are
expected to begin their defense one of
the senators who will hear those
arguments his Democratic presidential
candidate Elizabeth Warren and she joins
us now from Washington senator good
morning good morning so I think the
topic of the day is changing minds on
the one hand our minds being changed in
the Republican majority in the Senate
when it comes to the impeachment of
President Trump and in your particular
case our minds being lost in the fight
for a win in Iowa usually at this time
you would be on the campaign trail four
to six of it events instead you're in DC
so let's take those in parts number one
do you get the sense that Republicans
are listening and that potentially Minds
are being changed in Washington DC but
we have just heard an avalanche of
information about the corruption of
Donald Trump and many of the people
around him
and the Republicans right now in the
Senate seemed absolutely determined that
we can't have witnesses and we can't
have any documents in other words we can
only do what had happened at the house
they want to try to hide the information
that's not right and it's not the way a
trial should go this is what I promise
when I'm President of the United States
on the first day I'm going to release
every document I'm going to order the
release of every document that the Trump
administration is trying to hide but
senator one of the ardennes people have
a right to see it senator one of the
complicating factors here is because
you're present at this trial you are not
campaigning and therefore may not be
president are you concerned that by not
being on the campaign trail your chances
are sinking in Iowa and New Hampshire
look some things are more important than
politics I took an oath to uphold the
Constitution we are now in only the
third impeachment trial in the entire
history of the United States of course I
am here but I will tell you something
new that's happened that I had not
anticipated exactly and that is when I
first got in this race a year ago I
decided I wasn't going to do it the
traditional way I wasn't gonna spend my
time sucking up to billionaires and
other big donors corporate CEOs I was
going to do this by building a
grassroots movement 5 and $10
donations lots of volunteers because I
think that's how we need to repair our
democracy and build real change in this
country so now here I am pinned down in
Washington with the impeachment trial
and what's happened is this grassroots
movement on its own is saying we'll be
in the fight for you so people have been
going to Elizabeth Warren calm they
pitch in five bucks they offer to spend
an hour on the phone doing calls in
other words democracy itself is raising
its head go in across the nation and
it's very exciting to see but Senator in
the latest New Hampshire poll it has you
trailing in fourth place are you
concerned if you don't do well in your
neighboring state you can see the
numbers there that could seriously
injure your campaign I have not done
polls since the first day I got in this
race and I'm not gonna start now for me
look mostly it's been about a chance to
get out and talk to people and yes
that's what I'd love to be able to do
it's the face-to-face part of democracy
that matters but I'm doing my best I'm
here in Washington because that is my
constitutional responsibility and I'm
grateful to everyone who's pitched in
five bucks or volunteered an hour and
said we're going to be out there for you
and all the people who've shown up who
Leon Castro has shown up in Iowa this
brother Joaquin to say we're going to go
across the state and talk about the
issues that Elizabeth Warren talks about
Ayana Presley is going to be down in
South Carolina I'm deeply grateful for
every single person who stepped up and
said I know Elizabeth can't be here to
do it and she'd love to be able to I
hear all the for interrupting but I'm
worried about the time I hear all the
people you're grateful for how are you
feeling about Bernie Sanders these days
were you were you surprised at that
conversation where you accused him of
calling you a liar on national TV that
we all got to hear it were you hoping
that that would be a private moment
between the two of you and what is it
like between you and senator Sanders
today but first were you surprised that
we all got to hear that conversation so
Bernie and I have worked together for a
very long time
we continue to do so I said all I'm
going to say about this we're in the
middle of an impeachment trial the third
in the history of the United States of
America have you two worked out your
difference and the Democrats are all
working together on this we want to see
a fair trial we want to see the
witnesses produced and we want to see
the documents who's ever heard of a
trial where there are no witnesses and
no documents and right now that's where
the Republican senator Sanders worked
out your differences I'm not asking to
go back I'm asking to go forward no if
you were to ask you can ask this however
you want but you're going to get the
same answer I've said all there many
Clinton said that no one likes Bernie
Sanders and no one in the Senate wanted
to work with him is she right I'm not
going there look we are trying right now
to manage an impeachment trial and at
the same time to talk about why we're
running for president for me the to
actually come together I'm running for
president because I see an America that
keeps working better and better for
those at the top and worse and worse for
everyone else so that's corruption it's
about the influence of money and that's
a big part of what's at the heart of
this impeachment trial I want to get a
question to you on a campaign issue just
last night there was a video that
surfaced a lot of people are talking
about it today it's of a father who
approached you at an event and said you
know it's not fair I've saved for my
daughter's college education and now
you're talking about forgiving and
helping out all the people who didn't
save for Americans who were in that
father's position who felt they did the
right thing and you're bailing out those
who didn't what's your response
but we build a future going forward by
making it better by that same logic what
would we have done not started Social
Security because we didn't start it last
week for you or last month for you think
of it this way
when I was growing up I wanted to be a
public school teacher my family had no
money you think there was to these
peoples no what I'm saying is there was
a $50 a semester option for me I was
able to go to college and become a
public schoolteacher because America had
invested in a $50 a semester option for
me today that's not available and
kids have taken on a trillion and a half
dollars in student loan debt we have got
to back that up and say we're doing
better going forward that we're not
going to say the next generation has to
take on two trillion dollars in debt and
what the next one three trillion or four
trillion or five trillion we don't build
in America by saddling our kids with
debt we build in America by saying we're
going to open up those opportunities for
kids to be able to get an education
without getting crushed by student loan
debt all right senator thank you very
much we're up against the wall here we
appreciate you being on and we hope to
talk to you later on as his trial
continues you bet